-Speaking of your mom,
who is just a full delight,
and I'm always
so happy to see her,
you had a girls' weekend
with your mom and your sister.
-Yes, I did.
I wanted to share this.
I called my mom and asked her
if I could talk about this,
and she's like, "I don't care."
I really thought she'd protest.
You'll know
when I tell you this.
Whenever my mom and my sister
and my nieces, we get together,
we always kind of challenge
my mom to live her best life.
We always try to have her
experiment with things.
I'm not gonna
go into details about what.
[ Laughter ]
But this is one particular time
where my sister and I
were watching television
late at night with her.
My dad had gone to bed,
and we -- we told her --
We didn't force her.
She did it.
But we said, "Pick out
a porn movie to watch."
[ Laughter ]
And so we scrolled through,
and we were just like,
"Just pick a quickie one."
They're 15 minutes long.
I don't know why
they're 15 minutes.
They should be two minutes long.
But anyway...
[ Laughter ]
She picked "55-year-old
and Older Sexy Grannies."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-I found 55 to be a little bit
low number for grannies, but...
[ Laughter ]
So, we started watching it,
and the first thing is,
my sister -- we're watching it,
and my mom's like --
watching it like this.
And she goes,
"Who the hell would want to be
the cameraman
all up in that stink?"
[ Laughter ]
And then my sister -- 'Cause
we're not paying attention,
'cause I'm furiously taping
on my phone, you know,
sending to the grandchildren,
like, just crying, laughing,
and my sister goes,
"Rewind it! Rewind it!
Oh, my God!"
My sister Patty.
And we rewound it, and there
was a spot where he, like,
lays her over the couch,
and they're about to do it,
and he takes his hearing aids
out like this and goes...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then, finally,
we're continuing to watch it.
My mother's really studying it,
and she just goes,
"Who the hell
would want to watch him
in a close-up of scratching
his craggy-ass foot?
Who wants
to see this guy's foot?
I don't understand
why this is sexy?
Who wants to see his foot?"
And then I look
at the television,
and it was not his foot.
[ Laughter ]
Unless his foot has just
one big toe and a saggy ankle.
[ Laughter ]
That's not his foot.
-He was --
-Yeah.
-He was scratching it?
-Yeah. He was scratching it.
He was scratching
the length of it.
[ Laughter ]
-He probably had athlete's foot.
-Yeah. So, uh...
-That is fantastic.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
I mean, what a joy
to just be there for it.
Your mom has inspired you
in a lot of ways.
I know Kate McKinnon has played
this character on "Update,"
which is a woman
who watches soap operas.
-Yeah, this is my mom, Deenie.
-Yeah.
-She looks very much like this.
-Yes, she does.
-They did the wig exactly
like my mom's hair.
And I used to write her doing
my mom talking about the soaps.
Because my mom and I
still watch the soaps,
and we ADR -- ADR them.
[ Laughter ]
We Xerox them.
And my mom will call me,
and she'll go,
"Did you watch 'em today?
Oh, my God, were they good."
And she goes, you know,
"Mustache and Big Boobs went in,
and that baby's not --
you know that baby's not dead."
[ Laughter ]
And she'll text me things,
all of a sudden,
with no warning and go,
"You know that baby's not dead!"
And I'm like,
"Oh, the baby's not dead."
[ Laughter ]
But she does --
she's watched it for 40 years
and does not know
one character's name.
-That's great.
She calls them Big Boobs,
Redhead, you know, Slut Bag.
[ Laughter ]
You know, different things.
-Different things.
-Yeah.
-One last thing.
And hopefully
you're gonna come back
and talk about it
when it comes out,
but you were just in a film
that Amy Poehler directed
and is also in,
and it's basically all
of the group of women
from your era at "SNL."
Dratch, Ana Gasteyer,
Maya, Tina.
-It's called "Wine Country."
It's coming out soon.
And we did it for Netflix.
And it is such a joyride.
And it's basically --
We re-enacted,
with fictional characters
but kind of very close
to ourselves,
a trip we took
for one of our 50th birthdays.
-I cannot wait to see it.
-There's so much
fantastic stuff in it.
We'll be talking about it soon,
and giving
all the details of it.
But I might have a scene
with a lot of dildos.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-What more do have to hear?
Paula Pell, everybody!